the biggest move so far this week was
not a free agency acquisition the
biggest move by far big cat was the
trade that happened on Tuesday night at
8:00 p.m. Eastern let me just say this
folks if you're gonna make big moves for
NFL teams do it during working hours
because that's when people are looking
for things to do other than work and
they tend to congregate at websites that
cover sports they like to follow they
spend a lot more time at Pro Football
Talk comm if they're at work so make
these moves between the hours of 9:00
and 5:00 Eastern please the Odell
Beckham jr. trade came at 8:00 p.m. on
Tuesday night Eastern Time that blew up
the NFL world that turned Cleveland
upside down the Giants are upside down
we're gonna talk for most of this
segment about what this means for the
Browns what was your first reaction
Tuesday night when you saw that obj had
been traded I was shocked and I'll agree
with you during you know nine to five
hours would be preferred I was actually
in the middle of taping a podcast I was
shocked to hear it I think we all
thought that it was a possibility
because Jay Glazer and credit to him he
put this out into the universe about a
month ago
but I was shocked that it happened and
it seemed to happen almost like that
usually when this when these kind of
trades happen you hear the rumors you
hear the mumbles we heard that from Jay
Glazer a month ago but then it didn't
didn't it feel like it just came out of
nowhere
boom he's traded we didn't hear that
there were talks going on or anything
like that and I also thought it was
crazy because the Giants could have
gotten more they've Mis played every
single hand they've had in the last year
and a half and the Browns are gonna be
one of the most exciting teams in the
NFL next year there were vague rumors
coming out of Cleveland last week and
eventually Tony grossie of ESP and
Cleveland said the rumor is Odell
Beckham jr. to the Browns for guard
Kevin Zeidler plus more compensation for
the Giants when they did a deal last
Friday that sends idler to the Giants
for defensive end Olivier Vernon people
assumed okay that's it maybe they talked
about Beckham but they couldn't work it
out trade not happening and that's what
made it such a surprise when it did
happen because the belief had been that
the ship had sailed now there had been a
lingering thought that the 49ers would
try to get back them I don't know if
they were serious players in the final
analysis but but that notion that
Beckham was available was just kind of
hanging around even though the Giants
denied it and to their credit the Browns
saw the opening they put together enough
to get the Giants to not say no they get
the deal done and now the Browns have
when you consider the moves they've made
this offseason and when you consider
everything they did last year what a
transformation to the team but you look
defensively they've got miles Garrett
they've got Denzel Ward they've added
Sheldon Richardson you throw it over to
the offensive side of the ball where
they added Jarvis Landry last year Baker
Mayfield the first overall pick in the
draft Nick Chubb who was great as a
rookie and didn't nearly get to play as
much as he should have
you've got Kareem hunt who's been added
recently who at some point will
presumably be cleared to play again in
the NFL and you throw al doubt Beckham
jr. on top of it this is a Browns team
that instantly becomes a team that will
be carrying heavy expectations team to
beat in the AFC North is going to be the
belief although there are some people
who say it's steel is still the Steelers
know how you make that argument with
Antonio Brown and Le'Veon Bell out the
door where do we see the Browns fitting
let's start well broaden it to the AFC
generally but let's just start in the
division between the Bengals the Ravens
and the Steelers where do you think the
Browns fit right now I mean I would
probably sitting here right now pick
them to win the AFC North which might
sound crazy but I do think that you know
the way they finished last season and I
want to go back to that real quick this
all comes back to Baker Mayfield and
this is why you should if you have a guy
who you think is the future your
franchise you should start him Hugh
Jackson didn't start him he had to wait
till Tyrod Taylor was injured but John
Dorsey makes this move because of the
way Baker Mayfield played last year he
says this is the guy we know that we
have the guy let's go start putting the
pieces around him let's open this
championship window in Cleveland and it
all goes back to Baker Mayfield but yeah
I mean if we're gonna start the AFC
North the Bengals haven't done much the
Ravens you could say probably net got a
little bit worse maybe because they had
a bunch of guys leave and also we don't
know Lamar Jackson having that playoff
game against the Chargers after that was
the second that was the first team to
see him twice
he's now gonna play a whole season next
year where everyone gets to see him you
know gets the tape on him
all's AFC North teams will see him for
two times so I'll throw those guys to
this side and then the Steelers you
don't know what to make for the Steelers
because James Conner was just you know
he wasn't leaving on bail but he was 85%
of lady on bail and juju Smith Schuster
is still fantastic and the Steelers seem
to be able to get a wide receiver no
matter what I mean you look at the guys
they've drafted it's unbelievable what
they've done at that position so I will
tentatively say the Browns would be my
pick right now but I still think like
you said the Steelers will have someone
do you say about that yeah I think it
does come down to the Browns of the
Steelers and the thing about the
Steelers whenever the expectations are
high the Steelers find a way to not live
up to them but when the expectations are
low that's when the Steelers are
dangerous and there's gonna be a lot of
upset people in that organization in
that locker room wanting to go out and
prove that they can still get it done
and to the extent that Antonio Brown was
creating a distraction a disruption
there may be some some happiness that
he's out of the picture although you
hear different reports on whether or not
he really was a major distraction if Ben
Roethlisberger was the problem well he's
still there but you know what he still
plays at a very high level and I think
to the extent that they're trying to get
the most out of the final years of Ben
Roethlisberger's career Mike Tomlin
finally feeling some accountability and
pressure maybe that makes him better at
his job I think the Steelers could could
be a sneaky choice i I just I know from
so many years where I've seen the
Steelers be overlooked and disregarded
that seems to be the type of year when
the Steelers find a way to rally and
surprise everyone and remind everyone
that there's still the Pittsburgh
Steelers and look anytime you get rid of
Le'Veon Bell and Antonio Brown your team
gets worse on the field I don't think
anyone would argue differently but I
think there is an argument to be made
about addition by subtraction and that's
the fact that these lists last year has
been absolutely insane in Pittsburgh the
Le'Veon Bell situation went right into
the Antonio Brown situation it was
pretty clear when you heard offensive
linemen call out Le'Veon Bell early
the year that that locker room has a lot
of issues and now they probably have
less issues now I don't think Big Ben is
like the world's best leader but if you
if you take away a couple of the issues
maybe you can almost dumb it down in a
situation where hey this is what we got
and we got to make do with what we have
and I think the Steelers might have that
addition by subtraction on the locker
room side obviously the talent level
will not be the same yeah Jesse James
who was the starting tight end before
the 2018 seas and he was supplanted by
Vance McDonald last year he signed with
the Lions this week and he said at his
introductory press conference he was
glad to get away from the drama in
Pittsburgh he talked about the Antonio
Brown trade he said it had to happen
because things were out of control by
the end of the season so if that
perception is accurate this is a guy who
was in the building for four years in
Pittsburgh
maybe the Steelers do get better with
the decision to move on from Antonio
Brown I think the key is this because we
know Judy Smith Schuster can get it done
so he steps into the Antonio Brown role
who will become juju Smith Schuster will
it be James Washington who was
disappointing last year as a rookie but
how many chances is he gonna get with
Antonio Brown and Judy Smith Schuster
there can they get something out of
Donte Moncrief who they added this week
so these are things to be determined but
I think the biggest threat for the
Browns in the division will be the
Steelers and it won't surprise me if the
Steelers win the division and I think as
you know we settled into the idea that
the Browns have all these stars there's
inevitably gonna be a backlash because
people are gonna get sick of hearing
about the Browns and that's when people
may turn to the Steelers and say hey
maybe the Steelers can get this done but
regardless let's let's say both teams
make it to the postseason what do we see
the Browns doing when it's time to
compete with other great teams in the
conference because there are plenty of
great teams in the conference
you got the Chiefs you got the Chargers
the teams in the AFC South are no
slouches especially now that Nick Falls
is in Jacksonville you've got the
Patriots there's still the Patriots and
you know we're talking about all these
other teams at the end of the day the
Patriots still the Patriots can the
Browns compete with these teams not in
their division why not why not I'm not
really a believer in you know the to
soon thing I think last year was their
step forward year and you saw like why
wouldn't they be in a situation they
like the end of last year the best thing
that could have happened for the Browns
was that very slim like million to one
shot that they could make the playoffs
and they got into games that felt like a
playoff atmosphere they were in that
Ravens game at the end of the season
they felt like they were playing big
games in December and I think that that
was such an important piece to putting
this all thing this whole thing together
I think the biggest question is gonna be
Freddie kitchens what type of head coach
is he because we've heard it many many
times when you go from being a you know
coordinating there who doesn't have
talked to the media that doesn't have to
deal with the team's problems overall to
being a head coach it's a big leap in
personality matters and obviously it's
great that Baker Mayfield clearly wanted
him to be the head coach so you already
have that relationship intact and strong
but that is the biggest question mark to
me I'm not worried about Baker Mayfield
I'm not worried about the offense I'm
not worried about the defense I'm
worried about a coach who hasn't been
there done that when they're going to a
season with expectations through the
roof in a city that desperately wants a
winner and and along with the perception
that Freddie kitchens was hand-picked
for the job because that's the guy Baker
Mayfield want you know one of my
concerns for the Browns is will Baker
Mayfield become too big for the team and
in a roundabout way there's a little
wisdom to bringing Odell Beckham jr.
into the fold because now it's not the
Baker Mayfield show yes he's the guy but
obj is there too and he's going to be
drawing a lot of attention a lot of fame
and all of a sudden it doesn't feel like
it's Baker Mayfield Plus this supporting
cast it feels like the supporting cast
is on more equal footing because the
supporting cast is led by Odell Beckham
jr. and I think that's a very real
factor not that Baker Mayfield is going
to abuse the power that he has but
forgot to coming in one year and become
the guy to fill that LeBron James void
in Cleveland the way he did and
basically decide who becomes the next
head coach that's the danger as long as
he has good intentions and does things
the right way it'll be fine but I think
Baker Mayfield even with obj there could
end up with a lot of power but what we
saw last year was leadership was
performance was production and it was a
guy that the Browns had been longing for
for a
very long time and I still think
Mayfield is gonna be special but I agree
with you
if kitchens can't get it done let me
tell you this though big cat if kitchens
can't get it done they'll be lining up
out the door to coach the Browns the
next time that jobs open yeah that's
absolutely right that was a nice cross
sport reference there I didn't even know
you watched the MV I didn't know you
knew who LeBron James why don't but I
barely do it but Baker Mayfield leads a
force of personality like he is a
franchise changing guy and III see what
you're saying when you have the
perception that it was basically his
coaching search like Baker Mayfield did
the coaching search he picked the guy
but looking at look at a place like
Green Bay where they have not empowered
Aaron Rodgers and that intention starts
there when you go the opposite direction
so if I have a guy like Baker Mayfield
who I think is gonna be a franchise
defining guy who not only is a good
quarterback but a personality where he
can basically change like the last 20
years of Cleveland Brown football I'm
gonna give him as much power as he wants
honestly like what what is that a bet
why is that a bad thing I players have
power we learned it this this offseason
Antonio Brown had power over the
Steelers and he took it without you know
what I mean like he just took it away
from them Baker Mayfield should be given
as much power as he wants because he's
that type of guy and and here's where I
mentioned something that's gonna piss
everyone off in Cleveland cuz I talked
about this with WEEI during Super Bowl
week laying out the future for Baker
Mayfield if there really is dysfunction
in the ownership ranks this was right on
the heels of the Seth Wickersham article
that talked about all the dysfunction
from the top of the organization on down
over the past several years and we talk
about the power that players now have
you know if Baker Mayfield ever decides
that that it's just not going to work
here because of ownership because of
dysfunction and heat and let's say that
they've got this grand experiment now
with Odell Beckham jr. and if it blows
up and if it doesn't work you talk about
players having power the moment Baker
Mayfield wakes up and says I want out of
Cleveland that's gonna be one hell of a
day and and Browns fans I'm not saying
it's gonna happen but they've got the
ingredients in place to be highly
competitive and contend you give the guy
that much power he may decide
someday he's gonna use that power to get
himself to another location and now
their drum shoes at the TV they're
throwing they're throwing their
breakfast at the TV cool in Northeast
Ohio you told me that Jim Baker Mayfield
you said I James Baker Mayfield saying
hopefully he doesn't get injured if he
gets injured you just said he's
basically leaving as a free agent I did
not say that I said if it doesn't work
out and there's this function at the top
of the organization and players have
power now more so than ever maybe that's
the next guy to use his power
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports